thanks Steven and I liked he's been
introduced me as I promote the use of
data science in public policy because I
that's pretty much what I do I don't
have to do anything real so the real
work is done by other people
I just come and promote the work so a
lot of people in the audience are
actually have been involved in those
efforts that I'm gonna talk about so
what I would like to do is start talking
about some really depressing stories
because you know it's after lunch we're
all tired so let's kind of bring the
energy level down as much as we can and
talk about some extremely depressing
things so depressing story number one
police misconduct we're all very
familiar with it unfortunately we're in
Chicago it's not a problem just limited
to Chicago you know the relationship
between police and and the community is
probably at one of the lower levels it's
ever been and it's not getting any
better and although the the the use of
data science isn't really you know that
is going to fix the core problem but one
way to sort of think about what this
problem how police departments have
tried to tackle this problem many years
is they've had these systems in place
where are called early intervention
systems and these systems are designed
to raise early warning flags when an
officer is likely to have what's called
an adverse incident with the public that
could mean excessive use of force
unjustified use of force a complaint any
type of injury and and so the way these
systems work today is they basically
don't work because they're designed by
people sitting on our table thinking
about what could be predictive of an
officer adverse incident say well
perhaps it's a the number of times a
complaint against him has been filed or
perhaps as a number of uses of force in
the past so here is an example of a
system that Charlotte Mecklenburg and
North Carolina had built and this is
pretty much the state of the art right
now
in the US and the system basically comes
up with that system comes up and you go
into the system it's clearly dotnet you
can see that and it comes up and you put
in a number of accidents so it says if
zero and this one right so if two
complaints have been filed three
complaints have been filed against a
person in 180 day period raise a flag
it's as if they've had two uses of force
in a 90 day period
raise a flag as you can imagine the
problem there many problem of the system
despite other than the dotnet problem
but that the the problem with these
things I haven't even started talking in
they're already not saying much yet okay
so the problem is one of the problems of
system is that these are not early
warning flags right these things have
already happened and you're telling that
the police department something bad is
happening
so one it's it's just the interventions
at this point are mostly punitive all
you can do is fire the person and
there's not much else you can do the
second thing is when you start looking
at the data behind it that these types
of flags raised that they they basically
flag a ton of officers so in the case of
Charlotte it turns out the system like
this flagged about 60% of the officers
in the department and it still failed to
capture about 20-25 percent officer who
ended up doing bad things in the future
right so it's not only inaccurate it
also is unreliable because it keeps
raising flags about everyone so the the
goal for a system like this is it has to
be accurate it has to identify as many
people correctly as possible but you
also have to minimize the number of
false positives and so what we started
doing was one started looking at the
system at the data behind these systems
and started getting data from
departments and building a system that
could do better and in this case we
worked with a few different departments
we started working with Charlotte about
a year and a half ago and we've kind of
added a few other departments to this to
this pool and we got data about
everything
they know pretty much about an officer
so their employment history their
demographic data their training their
any arrests he dispatches any citations
and he stops any complaints against them
whether the complaints were justified
unjustified what they investigated what
happened throughout the entire process
so you're basically seeing pretty much
everything they're sort of some
exceptions and based on all of that we
want to predict if this officer is
likely to have one of these adverse
incidents in the next period whatever
the period it but there's three months
six months 12 months 18 months and their
period depends on how much time you need
for that intervention to work if the
intervention is take him off the street
and put him on the bench that's one type
of intervention if it's a counseling
intervention if it's a training
intervention and what we were able to do
pretty quickly was find out that you
know using off-the-shelf machine
learning service methods if you sort of
structure your inputs properly if you
start sort of setting this up you could
pretty easily do better than the system
that exists right so we're able to do is
show that you can actually reduce the
number of false positives by about 50%
while increasing number of people you're
actually finding correctly but about 15
to 20 percent now what that allows
people to do is that actually makes it
an early intervention system as opposed
to something that's one not accurate and
to the interventions can't really be
useful you can start doing it early and
one of the extensions of that which one
of those teams the summer of this
fellowship program that Stephens talking
about was working on is how do I now
support other types of interventions for
example when you're doing a dispatch
where the police about a police
dispatcher does today is a call comes in
and they look at sort of what type of
holidays they look at Sophos errs are in
in the area and they try to kind of
dispatch the nearest officer to that
call now what if we could predict that
this officer is at high risk of an
adverse interaction for this dispatch
what if that professor was two minutes
away in the next officer was three
minutes away but at a much lower risk is
the urgency of that call low
that you could sort of make that
trade-off could you be smarter about who
to send not just based on the distance
and the type of dispatch but also their
risk so we're finding pretty good
results dispatches are a very you know
they happen all the time in a very small
percentage of those dispatches end up
being adverse incidents so you want to
be very careful about how accurately can
you predict those things and then how do
you prioritize those things so that's
sort of depressing story number one that
that's happening today and I'll I'll
sort of try to go through a bunch of
examples opposed to going too deep but
feel free to ask me questions as well as
I can point you to more detailed
write-ups of these things including the
github repos all these things are public
so you can take a look at those things
as well so depressing story number two
this one actually takes place in Chicago
its lead poisoning and a lot of you are
probably more familiar with that
poisoning now than you were we know six
nine months ago mostly because of Flint
but it turns out that that poisoning the
major source of lead poisoning is not
lead water and pipes it's really led in
paint so every home built before you
know the u.s. before 1978 has let paint
in there and that paint is fine as long
as that stays inside that wall but as
homes get old let starts coming in old
paint start chipping kids when they turn
you know twelve months eleven twelve
months they start crawling and when they
start crawling they pick up lead dust
with their hands they put in their mouth
it goes into your bloodstream and it has
pretty horrible effects lower IQ hearing
loss memory loss motor control issues
all very bad things the worst of all
that all those effects are irreversible
once there is lead in your in your
bloodstream there's not much you can do
to reverse the damage so the way we deal
with that problem today is we wait until
somebody is that poisoned so for example
city of Chicago every kid is supposed to
get tested their blood supposed to get
it that's it for lead levels and when
they get tested if there is an elevated
bed level the health department gets
notified the health department then
sends a team to the home where the kid
lives to check for lead hazards and sure
enough they 98% time they find that
hazards there
because the kid got poisoned so the
going check for let they find it and
they figure out how to remediate those
problem which means it repainting the
wall or replacing doors or windows if
it's in there now the problem there is
obvious right where the damage already
happened by fixing this home we're
protecting future kids who might live in
that home from that poisoning but the
kid who just got poisoned well two bats
or policy effective policy today as we
use kids as let sensors to detect lead
and then go and fix the problems because
they're extremely accurate sensors it
sounds horrible but that's that's that's
our policy for all practical purposes
now to their credit you know they
realized that was a bad policy but they
didn't know what to do about it so they
came to us said well is there a way we
can find out before they get poisoned
and and do something about it before so
we started working with them on getting
data for about the nice thing is a lot
of these problems the data already
exists it's being stored for compliance
and regulatory purposes and now we can
sort of repurpose it to do more useful
things right so data that existed in
this case was every blood test in
Chicago was storage and I mean you know
which kid where they live and what was
their blood that level the second thing
we had was access to data to every led
inspection that was done so we know this
home was inspected on this date and
whether lead was found or not and then
some information about remediation in
the future you could now augment all of
that with some open data about home
structures you know in this case you've
got you know pricing for the house what
structure was what material when was it
built how many rooms are there how many
floors all of that stuff using all of
the data what we could do is basically
structure this problem so that what
we're doing is taking a kid just like in
the police officer case at a particular
age and that age could be anywhere from
negative six months so if somebody is
pregnant we can start from there and say
hey if the kid were to be born in this
address how likely is this that this kid
is gonna get lead poisoning or it could
be as late as you know 12 months because
you don't want to predict after that
because it's too late um so we pick
every kid but mean that age and
we can predict what's the risk that this
kid is going to get lead poisoning and
now if you can predict that then we can
direct our inspectors to go there before
the kid gets poison and start fixing the
process and the reason you want to
dearly do it before birth is so that you
have more time because once the kid is
born one you have to do it pretty
quickly but two there is some reason to
believe that you know when you go in and
do you basically drill into the wall
when you drill into the wall to check
for lead dust comes out so is a slightly
elevated chance is still better than not
doing that but so now so that we were
able to show that you know we can fairly
accurately compared to what they were
doing before which was nothing right
it's all reactive so we're not saving
any kids compared to that we could do
these preventive inspections so that you
could start remediating these homes
before the kid gets poisoned and so what
the city is doing right now is we're
doing two different things one is
they've started a pilot basic an
experiment that's comparing if they were
to do their process as they were doing
and if they were used this predictive
model how how much better would we do
the second thing we're doing is working
with a couple of hospital systems to
implement this into the electronic
medical record system so when a parent
woman comes in for a checkup
it raises a flag saying hey this kid
who's gonna be born is likely to have
light poisoning that's gonna go back to
the health department just like the post
poisoning report was going and so that
now they have time to go in prioritize
and allocate the right resources so
Story number three high schools about
you know thirty something I'm gonna try
to see if I can turn this thing off or
reply maybe okay so number three about
you know thirty percent of of high
school students drop out or not graduate
on time in the US and that number is
pretty similar to you know most of the
developing countries in the world so
pretty bad shape and at the same time
you sort of hear about there's a lot of
money being spent on support programs
after-school program so there's a lot of
funding there to create these programs
and it's not affecting the dropout rate
very much and so one hypothesis a lot of
people have is that we've got these
programs but these programs are not
really targeted at the right kids often
these programs are opt-in so you have to
go sign up or a parent has to go sign up
for these programs and that somehow to
know typically defeats the purpose of
having these programs because a lot of
kids at risk
they're not gonna opt into these things
so one of the challenges a lot of
schools face is that they don't really
know how to prioritize the kids that are
at risk because just like again the
police system a lot of these systems are
built by you know three experts sitting
around a table thinking okay so the GPA
of some student is less than 2.9 that's
probably at risk and if they've missed
more than three days of school they're
probably at risk if they've had for
disciplinary you know actions against
them then they're probably at risk now
what that does is again it Flags a ton
of kids and so you miss a bunch of kids
who are at risk
so you miss a bunch of kids where you
know [ __ ] not in this set but also when
you intervene on 60% and 40% for names
to the kids a lot of those interventions
are not are wasted because you could
have taken those interventions and
applied them to kids who originally
needed them so again you're being
inefficient and you're missing a bunch
of kids there's this mismatch so we
started looking at with several
different schools around the countries
work with Montgomery County economy in
Maryland Cabarrus County in North
Carolina Mesa in Arizona
and then about 15 school districts this
summer in southeastern Ohio how they
build a system that's able to accurately
identify the kids who are at risk and
the it's very similar to the previous
two things right you take everything you
know about a kid and instead of three
experts sitting around table and trying
to come up with these things you use
data and you take everything you know
about a kid and predict how likely are
they to drop out in the next year two
years three years four years five years
and so one of the results we found this
summer and so we've kind of shown that
it can it works on a lot of different
different school districts the the team
that was working on it this summer one
of the interesting results they found is
that you know in ninth grade
tenth grade um schools are pretty good
at identifying some number of kids who
are at risk what we can do with this
additional data and machine learning is
we can identify the same kids three
years earlier so instead of waiting till
the tenth grade to find them we can
identify the same number of kids in
seventh grade so now the school has
three extra years to figure out how do I
figure out how to keep them in school
how do I make sure they graduate school
what perhaps the programs actually work
and one of the things they're going to
keep in mind is you know what I'm
talking about here is sort of the
identification problem right can I
identify and prioritize the kids who are
most at risk and I'm hoping that the
interventions that exist are actually
able to change that behavior and so
that's that are the next piece in this
type of work in the lead case I know
that if I can remove the lead from the
house it will not you know that kid will
not get my poison because I know the
physical process of that poisoning you
ingest lead it goes dears if I take out
the lead you're fine in the case of of
dropping out of high school needing
extra support I don't exactly know what
kind of program works for you because a
lot of the studies that are done are
kind of talk they talk about average
kids on average you know this
intervention helps kids 3% now what
about the kids who are really high-risk
do I know if that works for them because
I don't know who those kids that are I
can't test interventions so another sort
of side effect a byproduct of this type
of targeting is you can start designing
interventions that are specifically
targeted at kid who's who are high-risk
and then you can start validating that
so you can test whether your
interventions are actually effective or
not so another example that serves our
prioritization and targeting this is
some work that we started doing with the
EPA about a year ago but it's also an
extended through some other
organizations and here the idea was to
so EPA for example is there's a bunch of
different regulations they have to
enforce one of them is around getting
rid of hazardous waste and what they
need to do is to figure out you know
they've got half a million facilities
around the country that generate
hazardous waste and they have a handful
of inspectors who go into the
facilities and inspect things and this
is a fairly common problem right
organizations have access to a ton of
things and they can only investigate a
few of them and their goal is to enforce
across all and so what they end up doing
is you know again some experts sitting
around a table deciding which facilities
should be inspected this year we can
inspect the ones we have an inspector in
a while we can inspect the ones we date
who violate regularly we can inspect the
large ones we can inspect the ones that
are near where a lot of people live or
where there's water sources so you don't
have waste going into rivers and they
end up doing that and end up finding
sort of you know some percentage of
facilities that are that that are
violations so we started working with
them and say hey can we make you more
efficient can we start targeting
facilities that are much more likely to
be at at risk of violations and then you
were doing before and again the process
is very similar you get historical data
about all of their inspections and you
start building models that predict which
facilities likely do to to violate and
in the future one tricky thing here is
that you know when you start working
with them their goal is efficiency they
want to make sure every inspection they
do is a violation because that's what
they live for
but their goal if you start thinking
about this the goal here isn't finding
violations
the goal is enforcement and the goal is
deterrence right so if you were doing a
thousand inspections a year and you
found a thousand violations but in your
set of the other you know four hundred
ninety nine thousand the violation read
kPa rate kept going up big that would be
failure so you would be very efficient
but completely useless because you care
about minimizing the total violation
rate not the found violations that's a
very common problem and people do
inspections is they try to focus on the
efficiency part and forget about sort of
the actual deterrence so the first step
was really you know if we started
telling them to do fix that problem they
would never even starts the first that
was really can we make you more
efficient and once we've made you more
efficient the next step is to kind of
move on and start doing the deterrence
problem which we're kind of getting
going to get to in the near future but a
very similar problem also occurs in
cities so this is
a home in Cincinnati and Cincinnati like
many other Midwestern cities is
shrinking City right so people are
moving out of the city and there is a
lot of flight homes are getting
abandoned that's spreading to different
neighborhoods and it's in pretty bad
shape and so one of the tools they
wanted to use so most cities when would
they deal with blight so take you know
Midwest take Memphis Detroit a lot of
other cities the way they deal with
blight is very similar to the lead
poisoning example is they let it happen
and then they go and try to fix it in a
reactive ways they'll try to get
investments into a neighborhood try to
bring it back up try to get and that has
other side effects that may have a good
or bad but it's much more expensive to
do it later it's already affected
people's lives and it's already affected
the economy of the city so what's inside
you wanted to do is see you can we again
do it in a proactive way in a
preventative way and one of the tools
they had access to was home inspections
so home inspections are typically you
don't use to an enforce code right where
somebody says you know your here's your
roof has to be the structure or they go
in say that's not right it's not sable
its and used inspect the home you find a
violation you get them to fix it
well they wanted to do would say well
can we use these inspections to find
code violations that lead to flight
whether that means that it's gonna lead
to home abandonment whether that means
that it's gonna lead to a home
abandonment of that home which could be
a leading indicator to blight spreading
through that neighborhood so instead of
just looking at homes that might have
violations they wanted to look at homes
that have violations that could lead to
blight and again the process was pretty
much the same right where you get some
data you look at the historical
inspections you try to find homes that
are at risk but now you're trying to
figure out an additional thing of is
this violation just a violation or is it
going is it a leading indicator of
something bigger that could get much
worse you can prevent that from
happening in the first place I'll come
back to some of those things in a little
while so one more one last depressing
story in this depressing story is around
prisons and typically jails right so
they're sort of this our criminal
justice system is in pretty bad shape
right people want people keep cycling
through it over and over again and one
of the things you sort of actually
notice is when you look at people who
are in jails for very long time or for
multiple times it turns out that they
also interact with other services that a
city county or state provides so
homeless shelters emergency rooms mental
health facilities and so it turns out
that when you start looking at the
people so the if you look at the body
this is where the three systems right so
this is your emergency room on the left
side the largest one mental health
facilities in green and then jails in
the blue it turns out the people who are
going through the repeatedly going
through the system they end up being
produced proportionately kind of here in
these intersections in this Venn diagram
and it also turns out that that often
happens before long stays in in jails so
the hypothesis that we have here is you
know if we could identify the people who
are going to get stuck in those systems
later can we provide this information to
emergency rooms can we provide this to
mental health facilities can do provide
information to homeless shelters so they
could start doing preventative work so
that these people can be can be saved
from going into that system in in the
longer term so this is some forgive work
we very recently started in this case
with with Johnson County Kansas and some
of the results were finding are actually
very encouraging but the problem is you
can sort of say you know well sixty
percent of people who spent one year or
more in jail they had an interaction
that they went to the ER in the two
years preceding that well that's that's
not very useful because you know 0.0001
percent of the people who go to the ER
end up in jails right so knowing that
direction doesn't help you predict other
direction so what we were trying to do
is say what if we reverse what we've
said you are now in a mental health
facility or you're coming there can I
predict if you're likely to be at risk
of going
to jail in the next year and if I can
predict that can I give this information
to a caseworker or a mental health
worker and they can start working with
you and a minimum keeping in touch with
you as you leave there to make sure that
you know you have the support you need
and what we found is this is sort of a
graph of if you start taking the top
people that you're really confident
about that prediction how how efficient
can you be right so what we found is
that if you take the top 200 people were
predicting who at risk hundred of them
are gonna go on and to be in jail in the
next year and if you could intervene
with them and prevent that from
happening which is very big if because
we don't know if we can yet they were
gonna go on in the next many years to be
in jail for 7,000 years
I mean 7,000 days sorry that would be a
horrible it would I would actually you
know increase the lifespan by quite a
bit but it turns out it's on the top 200
we can find hundred people who are
actually gonna go on and and and be
stuck in jails for the next you know in
for 7,000 days so it's very early work
that we've started doing it I don't have
seen a very concrete results but it's
something that we're extending with a
lot of other jurisdictions so we're
working with Salt Lake County we're
working with Milwaukee and very similar
problems as part of a larger effort
around data-driven justice and criminal
justice reform so what I kind of stepped
back a little bit from these stories and
you know there are many such stories
that are on our website so go take a
look at a lot of these types of projects
that we've done over the last several
years and that are going on but one of
the things you sort of step back and say
you know when you start working with
cities nonprofits states counties you
sort of end up working with them trying
to teach them how do you think about
these problems how do you structure
these problems so they can solve them
using the tools we have access to and
you've sort of find certain templates
right so in this can come in and data
science for social good templates or
policy all the policy templates and they
kind of fall into mostly in these five
buckets or so the first bucket was can I
detect who's going to get lead poisoning
early right but the the template really
is can I detect something earlier these
are early inner
systems sorry early warning system so
whether it's for police officers or
whether it's for kids are gonna get that
poisoning or whether it's what kids who
are going to drop out of high school or
need extra support in high school or
people who are gonna go to jail in the
next year
it's an early early warning system the
second one is sort of can I can I
determine which home inspections to
prioritize or which people I want to
focus on or any other thing would I have
facilities and which facilities do I
prioritize to inspect and so that's a
prioritization problem where I know I'm
not going to be able to get to all of
them I have got this many things I can
only do something about this many which
one should baby in order to minimize
blight or do maximize violations or to
maximize deterrence effects the third
one which I didn't talk about very much
examples because they're slightly more
complicated examples where a lot of
times organizations have access to a
bunch of different policies and in this
case it was a project we were doing with
government of Mexico where they were
trying to reduce maternal mortality and
what they weren't sure about is you know
what we can do a bunch of different
things we can put more clinics around
people we can do better transportation
policies we can do other things which
ones do I modify how do I take the 30
policy that have access to pick the
three that to prioritize to test and see
which one is more effective the fourth
one is a very common one which is people
do stuff and when they do things they
don't quite think ahead about you know
what am I trying to really do but cities
design policies and they implement them
and then five years later I think what
impact did that have well it would've
been nice if you had planned that from
the beginning so you could actually see
which policy is effective so you can
then use that policy going forward but
that really happened so it's often if
you're going back and seeing which one
is having an impact and then how do i
optimize the future how do i design the
policy for tomorrow that's going to be
effective and the last example is sort
of you know we sort of in this community
net world we think of sort of data is
anything right it's it's it's data
everything is data in that world data
comes in rows and columns if it's not in
a row
it's not data and so in this case you
know it's like if the data happens to
occur in voice form or speech form or
text form or network for more video or
audio data so a lot of these project
people today I don't have data that
could help me do this and what they mean
is I don't have rows and columns that
can help me do this and so a lot of
these projects are all around taking
data that's not in rows and columns I
typically don't want to use the word
unstructured because it's very
structured I am talking to you in a
structured form you're understanding me
so it's a lot of structure in what I'm
saying
except it's not in a row in column form
so there's a lot of data and so often a
lot of these projects end up being
creating rows and columns out of lots of
different types of data and actually I'm
gonna skip through a couple of things
because I have I mean it's left a couple
of minutes left so if through some of
the more detailed thing with them talk
about around detection and basically
find a couple of minutes on when you
start doing these things sort of a bunch
of challenges pop up right which are not
necessarily technical challenges provide
oversee security which I'm not gonna
skip but but in interpretability so when
so if you're Google and you're trying to
figure out what ad to show somebody it
doesn't need to be interpretable it just
needs to maximize the CPA it just needs
to make sure that the highest cost
you're making the most money you can off
this ad when you're a public health
department you're trying to figure out
which kids to intervene because you're
gonna miss out on other kids you have to
be pretty clear on why this model is
predicting something you have to be able
to understand it because it could be
wrong could be making a mistake so for
us a lot of these public policy problems
interpret E is extremely important and
so the challenge is not to come up with
sort of when you're building of one of
these predictive models machine learning
is to explain the model overall but also
explain the predictions that each for
each person and those are two different
things and there's a lot of work that
people are doing right now around this
but it becomes much much more critical
when you're dealing with these things
that could affect people's lives and the
same is true sort of the next thing ray
which is transparency and transparency
is interesting because a lot of these
problems I talked about are adversarial
like where the police officers
if they knew so if you take the system
that says if you've done three bad
things in the past 180 days raise a flag
one of the things we hear from police
departments is that well an officer
knows that and they've had you know two
complaints against them it's been 140
days for the next 40 days they're gonna
be careful and they're gonna Cal for in
two ways they'll either not do anything
for those 40 days so nobody can complain
about them and that's bad or they won't
report things or they'll try to make
sure things are going to report it and
that's bad too
so we want to make sure that our system
is transparent because it's making very
important decisions about people's lives
you don't want to accuse somebody
incorrectly of something but you also
don't want the system to be so open that
people can game it so there's this
tension between transparency and what
I'm calling sort of game ability and
we're trying to figure out how do you
how do you best do this so that you are
interpretable and transparent but still
not too easy to gain the last piece here
is about again because we're dealing
with important problems about people's
lives we have a responsibility to be
fair to people and that becomes harder
and harder as these things get
complicated so for example if you start
predicting one of the things if you're
relying on historical data and the data
is biased because the decisions of who
you're sending to jail this is who
you're trying to prioritize our it
happens a lot in like lending practices
when banks have been making biased
decisions for a long time if you give
that system to a machine they're basing
and learn the same biases and propagate
them and even exaggerate them and that's
not fair so you can sort of look at some
of that and audit those things and see
are you being fair to people or there
are predictions fair even though your
data may not be fair but the second
thing becomes who are you making
mistakes on because none of these
systems are going to be perfect
and you're gonna make mistakes are you
making mistakes unfairly about certain
types of people because you don't have
enough data on them so we kind of need
to make sure not just that we're making
these predictions correctly and fairly
but that are the ones we're getting
wrong are not biased towards a certain
group of people and that's an really
important and challenging problem here a
couple other
they knew that you know one of the
things gonna also makes sure the people
who are working on these problems have a
skill set that is not just a skill set
of you know I know Python I know
scikit-learn right that is not enough
that's necessary but it's it's not even
close to sufficient so what we're sort
of found over the last several years
working on these things is you want to
have a collection of these good yeah you
want to know programming because that's
the basic life skill but you also want
to know how to formulate a problem
because if you can't formulate that
problem that code isn't gonna do
anything useful to anyone and you also
want to make sure you communicate the
impact of that problem just to get that
data and collaborate with the government
agency you can't just go in walk with
them and say you have a really important
problem that I can help you solve you
have to sort of communicate with them
both in the beginning of that during
that and then almost most importantly at
the end of that so they actually are
able to do something with what you've
you've spent time doing you wouldn't be
able to reason about ethical issues
around it and legal issues you want to
know what HIPAA means because that's
gonna be the first word you hear from
the other side but HIPAA it's like yes I
know what it means here's how it works
here's why I know this is okay and
here's how you protect against it and
work work with that system you want to
know how to design experiments because
it's not gonna be all data analysis
that's gonna be historical data but
moving forward to validate these things
it's it's gonna be a forward-looking
actual trial and experiment and you need
to know you know social science and even
machine learning so there's a larger set
of skills than you need then just a
specific you know knowing how a machine
learning works and how computer science
works and it's a much broader set of
skills that you need to build it's
basically that's kind of what I had I
want to end with yeah if you want to
know more about a lot of these things uh
the the description of these projects
are on our website there's also a github
repo most of the code is open source if
it's not because we this program just
the summers just finished yesterday and
so what we end up doing is take a few
days to clean up the repos of any
passwords anything else and then release
the rest of them on open source so that
the ones that a couple of ones I talked
about are not going to be there for the
next
but everything else is there and then
papers and descriptions are also over
there so and if people want to get
involved this type of work you know
happy to talk more either find me after
this or email me happy to talk to people
about if you guys want to get involved
any of these things but thank you it's
the wonderful Apple Twitter connection
yeah
yeah yeah so the question is you know
how do we know something isn't herbal
how do you measure that and I don't
claim to know the answer here it for me
it's very much the evaluation for me is
a user study given to models that let's
say one of them is better in some other
metric how much more likely is your
interpretability going to make this
person use that model I think so it's
not I don't think it's a technical
definition it's not it can be described
in n words or fewer or the information
content of that description is you know
in some number of bits you can do some
entropy it's not it's not about you know
minimum description length it's not any
technical thing it really does a human
who's making a decision given this
interpretation is is he or she more
likely to take the right action which
basically means I think what we have to
do is come up with different methods to
interpret different models I don't think
it's this model is more interpretable
than that one I think it's more we think
of inter durability as a separate
function that a model comes in and out
comes from this interpreter Lilly
function an explanation not just for the
whole model but for each prediction and
now you're giving this human enough
information so you're giving them a way
to explore the model understand the
predictions it could be I'm gonna give
you this person prediction is this
person is likely to be at risk because
look at these ten other people that you
did something to in the last week and
eight of them were just like this person
and they ended up doing this so I don't
think there is a there's a technical
objective answer here I think it's
really giving people tools to explore
and understand these things and then
seeing which ways get them to do the
right thing more often than not but it's
it's not going to be a you know we're
gonna use logistic regression because
everybody understands odd ratios yep
yeah so that's why I was gonna go
through a little bit so the question is
you know how how accurate are these
models and and the two metrics you care
about are you care about false positives
so how many people are you intervening
on that didn't need that intervention
the second metric is false negatives the
kids who would have dropped out but
you'd but then who did drop out but you
didn't identify them and typically what
you see is it's not exactly the same
thing but you end up sort of seeing this
type of graph right where in the and so
on the left side you've got how accurate
are you so if you identify so for
example over here we're saying if hey if
identify five my off my top five hundred
confident predictions I am right about
forty percent of them so forty percent
of them did drop out let's say and
there's a red one is of all the people
who dropped out how many did you capture
in the top five hundred so this is if
you just take this point right this
point is forty over here and about
probably thirty over here so this says
in the top five hundred forty percent
they drop out and of all the kids who
dropped out thirty percent of them were
in the top five hundred so you wanna
it's not you know you don't wanna pick
one point on this graph you actually
want to plot the entire things you can
then figure out based on your
intervention how many resources you have
to intervene and if you only got you
know interventions four hundred kids you
want to see which which model do I pick
because each models gonna give you
different curves like that and you want
to sort of give that as a menu to the
school district or the health department
and say okay let's figure out what the
right place to intervene is so and so a
lot of these results if you look at some
of the papers that we have they're more
sort of these types of graphs for
different types of models for different
types of problems for different types of
school district so as you do there
across you get those routes that are
very different so you can't say you know
in in general for any problem you get
eighty percent and 60 percent it's gonna
be very different based on how far out
are you predicting if you want to
predict you know the day before they
graduate whether they're gonna graduate
tomorrow or not that's much easier than
five years before if you want to predict
at a student level versus a class
level or a school district level that's
much no individually is harder than
group level but sometimes you have group
interventions where I'm gonna put all
these kids into an intervention if you
want to predict about an event that
doesn't happen very often so if you're a
school district that only six kids drop
out a year versus a school district
where 10% of the kids drop out that's
the more data you have about a phenomena
it's easier to predict so so there are
different variables that make a behavior
more or less easy to predict using these
methods yeah
yeah I mean something we've tried to do
a lot for going to move to more that
where the need is higher in in
geographies and countries the biggest
challenge we have faced is that a lot of
those organizations are not collecting
data in a digital format right so a lot
of data is in on paper if you're lucky
or in PDFs if you're less lucky but it's
it's and it's not the PDFs you know that
you easily part it's actually literally
just pixel pixel pixel pixels in a PDF
so the biggest challenge is really
having that data and so one of the
things we've been doing if you go on our
website as we call this data maturity
framework is it's not a technical thing
it's basically different dimensions
unless you need to collect data how
often you collect it at what level okay
Larry in what format does it have unique
identifiers can it be linked and that is
mostly for people who are not here yet
they're not the level where they can
just run these things but that's
motivation for them if you want to do
individual level predictions of this
type of in three years early you need
this type of data and so a lot of I mean
the code is there it's the challenges
the data isn't there and then the
awareness that this is a problem they
can solve that's not there so the best
way to take it to them is to kind of
motivate them saying you have this
problem in order to solve this problem
you need to collect this data once you
have this data here's an approach that
helps you get from because the middle
part is easy it's the getting them to
care and then understand that they can
do this and showing them a path to get
there but happy to help with any event
if you're interested I'm happy to help
with with some of those things
yeah nothing that's that's a but if they
had the data then the you know you can
see then you can start start small where
you can just give them a list of kids
most at-risk and if they start testing
that if that works then you can move
slowly as opposed to you know a big five
year implementation you can generate a
list in Excel
right you can do this the output is a
ranked list you can give them an Excel
spreadsheet and they'll look at and say
oh yeah those kids are so I think they
need to kind of feel that this is that
they can understand it that it's not a
massive you know black box that's doing
magical things because it's not it's not
that complicated yeah so yeah whenever
you want me to stop a lot of question
okay
yeah so the question is you know have we
thought about using intervention
historical intervention data whether
it's controlled intervention or whether
it's just a natural something happened
one of the challenges so we've done that
in some cases one of the challenges is
in most of these cases it's common
across pretty much all of these areas
interventions never get recorded or
rarely get recorded especially at an
individual level and that's one of the
things we're trying to do is so that's
what's one challenge the second
challenge is most of the studies that
people do an intervention with the
natural or in a controlled environment
they are on and it's basically a random
sample of kids and what we're trying to
do is you know yes this intervention
works on an average kid but the coupling
of prediction and intervention that's
what we really need to do right so you
don't care if this intervention works on
kids who are 98% likely to graduate you
care about how effective is this
intervention on this kid and that data
is really really really hard to find
because a lot of those interventions
aren't there yet so one of the things
we're hoping to do is starting with this
targeting once we can identify the kids
who are at risk then we can get these
schools to apply interventions on those
kids and then we can test and see which
kids intervention a work on which kids
intervention kit didn't work on so that
we because the outcome is you've got 5
interventions and I want to provide you
a rank list for every intervention of
kids you want to put into those those
interventions and we haven't been able
to get that get that intervention data
so if you know of anybody who's doing
that an individual level happy to you
know talk more about it but thank you